whether you want to be a martial artist
like Bruce Lee a successful weightlifter
a ninja psych the Hedgehog or Goku it's
important that you focus on explosives
training in your workout so you me I
enjoy working out in ways that make you
feel a bit like a ninja I go to the gym
to get my dose of action and to feel
like an action hero and that's why I
love the idea of training in ways that
can improve my explosiveness my speed my
jumping height and then I like swinging
on the monkey bars and lifting heavy
weights it just you know makes life feel
more like an action movie instead of
just sitting in a office somewhere
pushing pencils and if you're
interesting that kind of thing then I
think explosive training should be first
and foremost in your workouts because
you know that's what it's all about it's
about performance and explosiveness and
performance pretty much go hand in hand
[Music]
so this is your starting strength to
ability to call upon your maximum force
rapidly to recruit those muscle fibers
quickly when you need them so it is
really important in athletics because it
allows you to run faster jump higher
important in martial arts as lets you
punch harder and faster and it's
important weight lifting because a lot
of weight lifting moves actually require
a lot of explosive strength but a lot of
regular training routines that the
average gym rat follows do not involve
much focus on explosive strength and
thus they lack that kind of explosive to
the cavity that is necessary for so much
force and stuff just a little background
here that your muscles are made up of
muscle fibers and muscle fibers exist on
a spectrum where one and you have the
slow twitch muscle fiber and at the
other end you have the fast twitch
muscle fiber and there are various
points in between that slow twitch
muscle fiber is used for endurance
exercise it can exert sports for a long
period of time without tiring out and
fast twitch muscle fiber is used for
explosive force but it's--it eats
quickly in order to use fast which
muscle fiber you need to challenge it in
that in order to require it so if you
lift something like and your body is
going to opt to choose the more energy
efficient but less powerful slow twitch
muscle fiber and that's training with
exercises that will require you to use
that fast twitch muscle fiber is the key
way to improve your ability to do that
and it's your ability to not only engage
the fast twitch muscle fibers in your
connection between your brain and the
muscle and the neural structures inside
your brain representing the movements
you want to perform it's also the amount
of fats which muscle fiber you have in
your body compared to the slow twitch
muscle fiber which is somewhat genetic
as we're going to see it's somewhat to
do with your training so that in mind
how do you go about training your
explosive strength we'll start with the
stuff that everybody knows so everyone
knows or a lot of people know that you
can train explosive strength using
plyometrics
plyometrics or exercises that include
things like clapping press-ups
or jumping or any kind of exercise that
involves suddenly and powerfully
exerting strength so this is the seds
principle as is best said being specific
a patient to impose demands if you want
explosive strength you move explosively
but you can also do is you can train
explosive strength by looking at the
weight as well because as far as your
body is concerned there's very little
difference between natural weight and
the speed with which you're moving so a
clapping presser is similar to lifting a
large amount of weight because you're
trying to push yourself harder so if you
want to engage fast twitch muscle fiber
during your regular workouts or the way
you can do this and all you have to do
is make sure that you're lifting heavy
enough weight and specifically that
means 90 percent of your one rep max so
if you lift at 90 percent you're lifting
enough weight to engage the fast twitch
muscle fiber as long as you lift it in
an explosive manner so that's why it's
90 percent not 100% because if you did a
1 rep max most people are much slower to
recruit the muscle in that scenario it
takes a lot longer for them to exert
maximum force unless they're not
actually training their starting
strength to explosive strength they're
training their max strength so lifting
big heavy weights in an explosive manner
is a perfect way to train explosiveness
and a perfect example of this is the
snatch which is considered one of the
most explosive moves you can do but like
I say if you want to focus on something
specific like your running speed or your
jumping height then you want to train
those areas specifically in which case
you might use the plyometric exercise
such as jumping or running quickly of
course doing those 90 percents of your 1
rep max will also help you to improve
your muscle fiber recruitment in much
the same way that overcoming isometrics
does because you're trying to use as
much muscle fiber as possible you're
increasing the connection between your
brain and that muscle over the
neuromuscular Junction and using very
explosive training on a regular basis
whether that's sprinting or whether it's
lifting really heavy weights in an
explosive way it's also possible to
convert your type to a muscle twitch
fiber into type 2 X these are the two
types of fast twitch muscle fiber so you
can convert the be quite fast twitch
muscle fiber into the very fast twitch
muscle fiber and by increasing that
ratio you can gain more explosiveness
so I mentioned starting strength earlier
and that's because this is another term
that's kind of synonymous with explosive
strength starting strength is how strong
you are at the start of a movement so
for example in a curl you're starting
strength defines your ability to do that
bit of the move so if you want to build
your starting strength
just use partial reps partial reps being
repetitions where you're in a use part
of the movement and of course in this
case you're going to train that initial
first part of the movement this is all
fairly obvious so far right you've got
explosive movements great for training
explosive movements makes a lot of sense
not particularly interesting what I find
more interesting and more unusual is the
use of eccentric training so eccentric
training is essentially performing
negatives in bodybuilding a negative is
where you lift a weight that's too heavy
for you or you get to failure to the
point where you can't lift away anymore
you use your other hand or spotter or
cheat rotor to get that weight back into
the upwards position and then you slowly
lower it so this is the concentric
portion of a movement it's where your
muscle shortens and the eccentric
portion or movement is where the muscle
lengthens usually that means you're
lowering the weight or lowering your own
body so the eccentric portion of the
movement is something that we often
ignore we curl the way up as quickly as
we can or we press the weight up as
quickly as you can
then we just let it gradually lower
using gravity gravity does the work for
us but that's a mistake because training
your eccentric portion of your movement
can actually build a lot more explosive
strength and it has a lot of other
benefits too so you're actually stronger
in the eccentric portion of the movement
turns out you're 1.75 times stronger
than you are in the concentric portion
so by emphasizing that eccentric side of
the exercise you're actually utilizing
your greatest strengths and then what's
interesting is that this appears to
correlate with increased explosiveness
and there are lots of good reasons for
that because if you think about it when
you explode and you jump or whether you
throw you normally kind of crank back
first say for example if you're going to
jump you squat slightly and then launch
up and if you're going to throw
something you tend to pull your arm back
even with a punch you tend to pull
around back and then deliver the punch
and what this is doing is it's storing
energy by you I'm getting the muscle and
then contracting and it's got further to
move and it's got more stored energy and
the stronger your muscle is in the
eccentric portion of the movement the
more energy you can actually store and
thus the more explosive
you can become and it turns out that
eccentric training might also be useful
for improving your flexibility and
flexibility also plays a role in
explosive strength because if your flex
in the antagonistic muscle then it
creates less resistance so for instance
if I want to throw a punch I'm using my
triceps and my shoulder and my waist and
my legs but my bicep is actually pulling
my arm back and it's providing
resistance but if I have a more flexible
bicep perhaps achieved using eccentric
training then it's going to provide less
resistance and I can punch faster and
harder so you're improving your
flexibility you're improving your
ability to use maximum strength and
you're improving your ability to store
energy to use explosively when needed so
eccentric training believe it or not is
very effective for building explosive
strength so actually lowering the weight
slowly will help you to then move your
body much more quickly but something
even more interesting I found is to kind
of train the eccentric portion in an
explosive manner and the best example of
this is something like the clapping
press up again not because it's
plyometric because you're launching
yourself in the air but because you have
to catch your own body when you land so
you're lowering yourself and you're
slowing that momentum you're absorbing
the impact an absorbing impact is
essentially an explosive form of
eccentric strength and the same thing
happens if you're doing clapping
pull-ups when you catch the bar too slow
you slowly lower yourself the same thing
happens when you're performing catches
with anything else
this is catching a medicine ball or
using kettlebell juggling and so this is
actually why depth jumps are such a
powerful and effective way to train your
jumping height when you perform at depth
jump we jumping off of something higher
onto the ground then launching straight
back up into the air again and this has
been shown to train your explosive
strength in your legs over time it also
immediately results in a higher jump in
the short term in order to get the best
benefit from this type of training is
supposed to jump from something that's
45 inches high roughly maximum and you
should be on the ground for about 0.2
seconds before you launch back up in the
air again so you're barely spending any
time on the floor and the reason it's
supposed to be so beneficial is not only
because you're building the eccentric
strength over time but also because
you're generating more energy and
storing energy to then return back into
the jump and you might also be
potentiating the nerves and the muscles
ready to fire again and a more explosive
manner just FYI in case you couldn't
hell the depth jumps on performing here
are not a good example of how you
supposed to perform depth jumps
basically all I had to handle garden
chairs at was going to damage them and
they're sticking into the floor so yeah
I just quickly I tried to film in the
gym but I got self-conscious and there's
people staring at me so this is just
kind of a lame demonstration of how it
might work but remember you're supposed
to me spend 0.2 seconds on the ground
not however long I'm spending here and
yeah it looks a lot cooler when you do
it correctly you can use this kind of
training in your workout intermittently
don't do it too often because it is very
taxing on your nervous system so yeah
guys hope you found this video useful
and interesting if you did please
consider leaving a like comment down
below if you have any questions and I'll
try and answer you and subscribe to the
channel because if you enjoyed this
you're probably going to enjoy my other
stuff too I talked about briefly
training productivity brain training
martial arts and running faster jumping
higher that kind of stuff working for
yourself online if you find that
interesting and you'd like to make life
a little bit more awesome then yeah
you'll probably enjoy this channel
thanks so much to all of you who already
subscribed because the channel growing
now and actually I'm going to an event
tomorrow there's a 10k magic event by
YouTube they've invited me there because
the channels doing so well I'm loving it
I'm having a great time so happy it's
finally taken off and I'm getting an
audience - yeah just thanks so much for
making this possible and stay tuned for
the next one bye for now